leute es ist zu wenig wir schon mal
aufgefallen dass leute habe ich vor
einigen wochen ein video zu einem alten
video vom baby gemacht und zwar zu dem
ganz ganz alten video wo sie fremdgeht
tipps gibt leute dann vor einigen tagen
doch mal anderes video was auch eine
ähnliche richtung gehen leute und jetzt
ist wirklich zu lustig gestern am 20.9
2020 hat baby selbst eine reaktion auf
ihr fremd geht jetzt wieder geladen
ich habe keine ahnung ob das zufall ist
oder wie das vielleicht bei mir gesehen
habe vorgeschlagen bekommen hatten
deswegen da noch mal drauf kam auf jeden
fall wenn wir uns ihre reaktion mal
reinziehen damit haben wir nämlich darin
eine reaktion auf eine reaktion
vielleicht kann sie dann auf meiner
reaktion auf ihre reaktion reagieren und
ihr könnt den kommentaren reagieren
nicht reagieren auf die kommentare
also übrigens eine sache doch leute ich
sofort und natürlich meine kombiniert ja
auch so wie ihr mich sofort deswegen
schaut an colorful zitrone die sich in
bibis kommentaren diese reaktion
gewünscht hat werde kann ich ganz gut
verstehen wie gesagt leute also ich bin
ja mittlerweile auch sehr entspannt mit
diesen ganzen reaktion und ich habe
überhaupt keine absicht mehr irgendwie
runterzuziehen oder so ganz im gegenteil
insofern muss ich zugeben leute ich kann
es gut verstehen dass man so ein etwas
älteres video eigentlich eher unter den
teppich kehrt weil klar man entwickelt
sich um zehn jahren so alt ist dieses
video ja so extrem dass man
selbstverständlich eine ganz andere
person ist als damals ein bisschen quint
wenn man das sieht aber ich find's cool
dass sie einmal aufgegangen ist naja
also ja was würdet ihr sagen leute wobei
man muss man muss ganz ehrlich sagen die
die heutige babys wirkt auf jeden fall
noch mehr family friends die als die
alte das ist auf jeden fall sagen kann
so baby ist mit sicherheit eine sehr
professionelle youtuber rennen gehe ich
von aus und insofern gilt die safe auf
so einer professionellen ebene
natürliche bis wenn sie diese videos
heutzutage sieht aber es ist schon
geisteskranke ja wie wir heutzutage
einfach fast sechs millionen abonnenten
und damals die fremd geht jetzt die hat
sie übrigens im video gesagt für drei
euro oder so verkauft wurden
julian reagiert ob dieses video gerade
so
wer diese dieser ticker kommentare hier
leute aufeinander selbstverständlich
ganz ernsten ebene muss man sehr schnell
natürlich auch anmerken dass das mit
sicherheit für julian auch nicht leicht
ist nach dem mann mehrere jahre mit
einer frau verheiratet war man hat
glaube ich nach zwei kinder zusammen
2 dann zusehen wie die selbe frau im
internet fremdgeht tipps gibt da müssen
wir auch ganz ehrlich mal zu erhalten an
der stelle verständlich es ist es
verständlich muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen
stimmung komplett ruiniert achteten aber
dieses geschah auf die gesichter von den
beiden ist das wirklich die stimmung ist
wirklich am boden
sie dachte sich okay wir reagieren
darauf alte videos sie haben auch in
diesem video davor auf in allen reagiert
was aber wo ich keine beziehungen habe
das gibt aber die stimmung ist am
nullpunkt
diese stimme jetzige schlecht
[Musik]
das wird das geld wirklich wieso die
zehn jahre alte bewegt das ganze so so
mit so einem gewissen ton erzählt also
bis hin zu einer gewissen gerissenheit
in der stimme versteht was ich meine
so als hätte sie so date game
durchgespielt und wirst du genau wie man
alles richtig macht sie haben das halt
einfach echt für eine handvoll euro oder
so haben sie damals die videos verkauft
dann irgendein anderen kanal und der
kanal die heute noch online das heißt
selbst wenn sie eigentlich unbedingt
wollen würde dass diese videos wegkommen
was ob dies nicht der fall ist weil sich
selbst das video auf dem kanal hochlädt
dann könnte sie ist zumindest blech in
erster instanz wahrscheinlich nicht mal
weil der anderen kanal die rechte daran
hat man muss erst recht auf die
gesichtsausdrücke achten die leute wie
von 2010 ist
ja meine liegen herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen video
in dem ich sagen werde
ja auch sehr raffiniert und gerissen
weise ihren partner brink hat juliane
screens level 3000 babys so können wir
zumindest sowie weg machen leute diese
dieses grinsen dieses grinsen der zehn
jahre alten baby kommt
selbstverständlich nicht daher dass sie
es immer den peinlich fand sondern
aufgrund der genialität sie in diesem
moment verspürte das ganz ich selbst
sein dass ich aber sofort von zehn
jahren sich einmal ach so ja fünf euro
klar wenn man so mit seiner user anfängt
zu den fünf euro auch schon viel geld so
ich habe auch die ersten zwei jahre auf
youtube einfach zero verdient wirklich
zero da denken sie schon fünf euro
[Gelächter]
welche gesichts gewisse hier abgeht im
hintergrund denkt sich auch so mama papa
was etwas erzählt die mama
aber auch zu verlaufen
bloß nicht zu viel aufmerksamkeit weiter
das ist mit einer der größten fehler den
ihr in eurer beziehung machen könnt
haltet euch da wie gesagt eindeutig an
die 2010 an wie zu viel aufmerksamkeit
birgt das risiko dass der partner sich
tatsächlich geliebt für euch selbst
wahrscheinlich weiß was man unbedingt
vermeiden will mit dem kontext von dem
was sich alle reinziehen sehen die
ganzen smileys und kuscheltiere moment
ein bisschen schock aus aber also man
sieht nicht so wirklich viel mickey ist
schon eingeschlafen so aber das meine
ich so der tibeter okay dass andere
jetzt kommt das video wie man den
seitensprung entdeckt ja also
gottseidank netterweise war war damals
so freundlich auch für beide seiten die
tipps zu geben das heißt da nicht eine
seite über bevorteilt das ganze serviert
mit diesem leichten dauergrinsen auf der
rechten seite aber ich feiere ich weiß
ehrlich gesagt dass sie das nicht unter
den teppich kehren sondern darauf
eingeht bin ich gut
das land schon aufgefallen sind aber
mehr als nur aber da ist schon selbst im
jahre 2010 wurde an dieser passage schon
im original video gewünscht aber leute
leute so ist er so ist der stargast
extrageld jeder youtuber war an diesem
punkt wo er gerade angefangen hat wo er
regelmäßig videos hochgeladen hat und
wirklich kein cent hätte videos verdient
aber allerhöchstens passend und dann
musst du gucken wo dein land schon
herkommt ich sag's wie es ist notorisch
aber dieses video sieht auch im fall
bier auch tops für die entwicklung geben
diesen letzten zehn jahren hingelegt hat
sie ist von geheimdienstmethoden zum
herausfinden ob der partner über einen
betrügt ihn übergegangen zu einer menge
an einbauschränken mit einer fläche in
der ganz deutschland seine klamotten
unterbringen könnte schreibt er unter
den kommentaren was euch mal schauen
dieses widerliche kopf gegangen ist wie
findet ihr das video hier um einen kanal
bringen ich bin da schon raus musste